hi we're back here at the dev ox and i'm
here with Sam welcome Sam and we're here
to talk about media yeah I know the and
then the large grand scheme of things
media maybe before we talk about web RTC
which is obviously the topic we'll get
into let's talk about media and what it
represents in the web today do you want
to serve a few words about you know how
much the media is being consumed to do
sent on a shing yeah so I guess what
we've seen on the web is like kind of
two trends the first is sort of obvious
we have all these devices we're using
now get out more mobile phones than
pencils or toothbrushes all that stuff
but with that has come you know it's not
the same old same old is the change of
what we're doing on the web and you know
these devices which are kind of oriented
to consumption and communication in some
ways have led to a change in what we're
doing on the web and with that you know
we're getting the rise and rights of
media on the web figures I've had
recently from Cisco saying that within
like you know the next three years or so
we'll have something like potentially
ninety percent of web traffic we'll
leave video you know that's TV on demand
communication and so on but you know
that's that there's a huge shift in what
people are doing on the web right and
that means we need to evolve the
standards and as part of that the web
RTC plays a big I mean that's what
people what comes to mind so good tell
us about maybe a web web Archie is let's
start there yeah and well for those that
have yes not used it or that don't
really know what it is okay so we're
about to see is a way to do real-time
communication in the browser on the web
and its really well supported now on
Chrome and desktop for android Firefox
and you know desktop and Android and so
on and what it means is that plug-in
free royalty free open-source software
you can build that into your web app to
do you know the obvious use case stuff
like video chat right right in your web
app you know you can run a telephone
system in your web apps you can put a
telephone in a web app just like with a
few lines of JavaScript so we're talking
about replace say
existing potentially expensive software
that's been running you know this type
of abuse cases for the longest time yeah
with free open source open standards
yeah and and the cool thing is that web
RTC is designed to work peer-to-peer so
the existing of there the existing
frameworks you know we've had have
always involved a kind of centralized
model where you're running someone
else's services but essentially you know
the kind of core of WebRTC is
communication happens directly between
the peers which is much more efficient
once connection is established there do
you ever need any centralized now of
course to do this there's you know
there's nowhere this point in time to
dish out into the internet connect me to
my friend you know you can't do that so
you do need to negotiate the connection
by what's called signaling and then you
know we live in the real world with nats
and firewalls and all this stuff so we
also have something called the ice
framework that WebRTC users it's been
around for a few years and it's a way of
connecting even when you have these
complex networks and areas okay great oh
let's see what's new with web RTC you
know I feel like I've been hearing about
where by sea and then yeah I'll tell you
what I love at the moment what I just
I've seen amazing stuff with using the
other side of web RTC which is the
ability to exchange arbitrary data and
so not just audio and video but
arbitrary binary data or just text and
we've seen a couple of things with that
something called chef s which enables
you to share files between peers in a
completely peer-to-peer way you know
it's not going via some intermediary
server okay and that's yeah working very
well another similar application it's
got a prototype really called peer CDN
and you all you have to do is
incorporate like add the pier CD and
JavaScript top of your web page and then
what it will do is try to get the
content on the web page from a peer that
has the same stuff so the same images or
the same video or whatever so in other
words it's a peer-to-peer file
distribution setup using WebRTC so kind
of CDN via web RTC face that's pretty
cool that's pretty cool indeed so you
mentioned mobile devices
how real is WebRTC on those mobile
devices I mean there with usually the
mobile in terms of supporting the
standards and the advanced HTML file
female fighter yeah yeah it's kind of
trailing a bit yeah so when we stand
there it's looking good with web RTC so
all the api's implemented in chrome and
in firefox on mobile okay we've got
WebRTC bindings in fact for Java and for
iOS still work being done on the iOS
stuff but that's coming and yes so we've
got the ability to do that stuff on
mobile but also I think you know one of
the main concerns for us is that is
battery life as power consumption and
what we're seeing now is the integration
of hardware encoding so encoding and
decoding done in Hardware much much more
efficient much less power consumption so
that is a really huge you know focus of
the WebRTC team at the moment is making
that power consumption very very
efficient and working on hardware good
so um WebRTC just like many other fields
are filled with acronyms yeah so you
want to walk me through I like up I
think there's a thing or two that you
wanted to cover yeah mmse so to a couple
of related technologies we're using
video which the this something called
eme that people may have seen it it
stands for encrypted media extensions
this is a standard being developed by
the w3c to enable content protection
done via the browser interacting with a
drm system this means that you know
distributors and broadcasters can use
web apps without resorting to plugins
like flash and Silverlight the other one
I wanted to mention which is kind of
another one of these you know alphabet
city thinks is ms e which is media
source extensions this is kind of a
complicated way of saying that you can
put together a stream of video in
JavaScript from chunks of video now
what's interesting about that is that it
enables you to do
things like adaptive streaming so
raising and lowering first on you know
based on bandwidth and things like time
shifting and so on so yeah 22 of the
many you know API is adding adding
richness to video the web so how is
google using web RTC today yes so
obviously the movies for google hangouts
to be using web RTC right and yeah
that's of course gives us you know
better quality and the ability to do HD
between we hope you know more reliable
connections so that's that's of course a
huge push at the moment so we talked
about mobile how about accessibility i
mean people like vint cerf and for the
fact that you know and we pride
ourselves and making data available and
accessible how's that part being this is
something did in my heart I've worked
you know there is something called the
track element that you can use inside of
video elements in html5 and it's really
simple it's just a text file with
timings for what are called cuso
subtitles or captions and you prompt
that in a video element link it to the
text file it has that data and then
rendered over the video captions or
subtitles now that's cool but you can
also use that yeah it's great for
accessibility of course but you can also
use that by adding data in there instead
of just plain old subtitles so then
you've got this you know incredible
richness with the ability to add x
metadata essentially into a video so you
know a million use cases for that
awesome yeah that's very useful so um
you mentioned the video tag anything you
there yes some things I've seen recently
I you know I work with us on Chrome the
ability to use alpha transparency so
what this means is you can record a
video like a green screen video and then
in chrome now in I think it's still in
Canary but is coming to stable and it's
coming to mobile as well so cool is the
ability to have a transparent back
so you can do things like play one video
over another great for gaming great for
all kinds of use cases people have been
asking for this for a long time okay so
that's yeah I mean coming that's one
thing I love which is brand-new coming
to a chrome browser yeah yeah awesome
anything fun you've seen recently around
web RTC that you found amazing but
before I go yeah actually I was just
thinking what what's kind of really knew
I what I saw the other day I loved
someone had built for their own use a
baby monitor they like some techy his
wife had a baby he you know he was
feeling like he didn't want to just use
someone else's system so he did this
with WebRTC using like using motion
detection right so it's really cool so
it doesn't just sit there and like just
show you the video because that very
good did that already yeah so what it
does is it shows when there's some
movement and then you can do some
tweaking about when you might be a
notified get it some kind of alarm or
something so you can check when your
baby's working up and all this stuff
without having to just permanently
listen in but I love that sort of thing
you know people that sort of DIY right
developer spirit yeah that's what it's
all about yeah enabling these developers
with technologies inc and the sky's the
limit there's so many things ready we
haven't think thought about so now it's
great I mean to me this is a incredibly
rich api's and an amazing really i think
in an amazing feat of Engineering you
know just just amazing great well Sam
thank you so much that's all the time
about for having me but uh guys see you
soon yeah choose the next time